chers collègues monsieur kobinski nous
entamons aujourd'hui les travaux et vous
êtes le premier auditionner de cette
commission d'enquête sur les moyens
mobilisés mobilisables par l'État pour
assurer la prise en compte et le respect
par le groupe Total énergie des
obligations climatiques et des
orientations de la politique étrangère
de la France dans ce cadre nous
entendons aujourd'hui Monsieur Philippe
Kopinski docteur en sciences politiques
et plus précisément en relations
internationales
vous êtes chercheur et enseignant à
scienp au sein du Master International
Energie de l'école des affaires
internationales vous êtes également
consultant sur les questions
énergétiques internationales c'est au
titre de votre expertise concernant les
questions énergétiques mondiales que
vous êtes aujourd'hui auditionné par
notre commission vous êtes notamment
l'auteur d'un ouvrage sur le pétrole
ressources stratégiques dès lors vos
éclairages concernant la production et
la consommation d'hydrocarbures à
l'échelle mondiale nous serons
évidemment
précieux avant de passer aux questions
et aux
débats je regrette de d'avoir à faire
des rappels toujours un peu particulier
sur les
règles il me revient de vous indiquer
premier élément que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat la vidéo sera le
cas échéant diffusé sur les réseaux
sociaux puis consultable en vidéo à la
demande elle fera également l'objet d'un
compteendu public je rappelle en outre
qu'un faux témoignage devant notre
commission d'enquête est passible des
peines prévues aux articles 434 13 434
14 434 15 du code pénal qui peuvent
aller de 3 ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement
et de 45000 à 100000 € d'amende avant de
vous céder la parole je vous invite ce
que nous ferons pour tous les
intervenants hein à nous préciser si
vous détenez des intérêts de toute
nature dans le groupe Total énergie ou
des intérêts dans l'un de ses
concurrents dans le secteur de
l'énergie bonjour Merci euh non je
confirme je n'ai aucun intérêt d'aucune
sorte parfait et bien ce n'est pas
terminé pour autant je vous invite
maintenant à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure je le jure de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité je le jure ça suffit
après on va pas bon et bien euh nous
allons maintenant passer au questionn
alors vous avez reçu d'abord je pense
euh un questionnaire par écrit moi ce
que je vous propose c'est de faire une
intervention préalable de 10 15 minutes
si vous le voulez bien ensuite le
président et le rapporteur puis
l'ensemble des membres de la commission
vous poseront les questions nécessaires
donc vous avez la parole tout de suite
monsieur kinsk parfait merci beaucoup
juste une question pratique comment
puis-je faire pour passer d'accord
euh donc merci pour votre invitation
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur euh je suis très honoré de
pouvoir parler ici devant vous
euh il m'a été prés enfin j'ai été
présenté donc je vais pas répéter les
les choses je suis effectivement euh
enfin j'ai une expertise sur les
question pétrolière énergétique en
général dans une approche politique
géopolitique pardon économique social
également tout ça pour dire que j'ai pas
forcément d'énormes compétences
juridiques sur ces questions-l donc
peut-être qu'un certain nombre de
réponses je ne pourrais pas y répondre
euh je tiens également à dire que je je
j'interviens ici évidemment en mon nom
propre et en aucunement
aucunement de la part des des
institutions pour lesquell je travaille
euh j'avais alors j'ai préparé
effectivement une euh une petite courte
présentation avec voilà c'est magnifique
ça se fait quand même avec euh au fond
cinq questions qui me semble importante
de pouvoir répondre et j'imagine qui PEV
vous être util
pour vous éclairer par rapport à la
question de cette commission
d'enquête pourquoi le pétrole est
stratégique comment s'organise le marché
du pétrole peut-être aussi du gaz c'est
un petit peu des énergies cousines
est-ce qu'on va manquer de
pétrole est-ce qu'on peut s'en passer et
que peut faire le législateur par
rapport à l'urgence
climatique alors première question
pourquoi est-ce que c'est une ressource
stratégique premier slide vous montre
l'importance du pétrole dans le mix le
suivant euh dans le mix
énergétique mondial euh c'est pas passé
mais le pétrole est en vert ça c'est 31
% de l'énergie qu'on qu'on consomme
euh donc c'est important le charbon en
gris et le gaz en rouge c'est tous les
deux autour de 25 % grosso modo euh mais
ce qui fait l'important du pétrole c'est
pas tellement cette part relative qui
comme on le voit est en train de
diminuer que le fait
que c'est un produit qui a de
multiples avantages euh c'est très
pratique c'est abondant c'est en réalité
assez peu cher à produire il y en a
beaucoup et ça peut servir à tout et
slide suivant euh pendant dans dans
longtemps et en tout cas dans les années
50 60 après la deuxème guerre mondiale
ça a effectivement servi à tout
c'est-à-dire c'était aussi bien utile
dans l'industrie dans le transport dans
le chauffage dans la production
d'électricité puis je vais pas faire
l'histoire mais les les chocs pétroliers
et les crises pétrolières des années 70
ont rebattu un petit peu les cartes et
on a
progressivement réservé le pétrole pour
le seul usage pour lequel il y a pas
d'alternative c'est-à-dire le transport
et on voit que dans le transport c'est
en grande partie le pétrole routier le
le transport routier en vert sur le
graphique qui qui est le l'aspect le
plus important la navigation l'aviation
c'est nettement moindre et vous voyez
tout en haut du du graphique la part
relativement importante euh des usages
non énergétiques le pétrole c'est aussi
une ressource une matière première
fabuleuse qui permet de de fabriquer des
objets en plastique alors si on les
jette dans la nature c'est problématique
mais en soi c'est quand même quelque
chose d'assez d'assez pratique les
générations futures nous prendrons pour
des sauvages d'avoir brûlé avec autant
de de passion cette ressource aussi
aussi
cruciale donc le pétrole son côté
stratégique c'est parce que on en a
besoin pour la mobilité euh 90 % du
transport c'est à grâce à du pétrole et
le pétrole comme on le voit sur le
graphique c'est
essentiellement enfin c'est le débouché
essentiel du du pétrole sans pétrole pas
de guerre moderne alors on peut faire
des génocides à la machette tuer des
gens on peut le faire sans pétrole mener
une guerre du genre la guerre en Ukraine
il faut du pétrole même des gueras du
genre les islamistes au Sahel il faut du
pétrole et donc cet aspect stratégique
dont on s'est rendu compte à la Première
Guerre mondiale c'est ce qui fait
aujourd'hui la particularité du pétrole
alors je ne sais pas ça télécommande pas
non alors slide suivant s'il vous voulez
bien alors l'organisation du marché du
pétrole slide suivant première chose à
savoir c'est que bah comme c'est
indispensable pour le transport tout le
monde en a besoin et en gros plus vous
avez une population importante et plus
vous êtes riche plus vous consommez de
pétrole et on voit la la consommation
importante des États-Unis c'est 20 % du
de la consommation mondiale sachant
qu'ils sont 5 % de la population les
Chinois deuxème gros consommateur et
puis les Européens c'est c'est aussi
assez
important slide suivant mais quand on
voit les évolutions on voit que les
États-Unis ça stagne depuis les années
80 l'Europe ça a plutôt tendance à
diminuer le Japon ça ça diminue
franchement et l'essentiel aujourd'hui
ou depuis ces 20 30 dernières années de
la croissance du marché du pétrole c'est
les pays émergents et en particulier la
Chine qui occupe vraiment une place très
très
importante pour avoir un ordre de
grandeur la la production et donc la
consommation mondiale de pétrole c'est
autour de 100 millions de barils par
jour MB j les États-Unis la Chine et
l'Europe c'est 50 % ce
volume slide
suivant ça c'est la la consommation tout
le monde en consomme pas tous les pays
slide suivant s'il vous plaît
n nen produis non là ça c'était la
précédente ouais ça
fonctionne super merci ça c'est la la
production ce qu'on voit quand même
c'est que un il y a trois gros
producteurs qui sont
zut c'est pardon qui
sont les États-Unis la Russie l'Arabie
saoudite à E3 c'est un/ers de la
production mondiale mais on voit qu'on
produit aussi beaucoup enfin globalement
dans le Golf Persique et puis après oui
le Canada le Brésil la Chine le le
Nigéria sont aussi des producteurs pas
pas négligebles alors si vous avez la
consommation d'un côté la production de
l'offre Vous avez un marché et une chose
vraiment importante à comprendre c'est
que on est un marché qui est globalisé
et qui est libéralisé autrement dit
toute la production est disponible sur
un marché tous les acheteurs ont le même
marché et le même accès au marché si
vous voulez un baril de pétrole
aujourd'hui il vous faut 75 dollars ni
plus ni moins il vous faut pas une une
une multinationale pétrolière il vous
faut pas une armée puissante il vous
faut juste payer le prix
l'offre supply ici ce sont c'est pas les
pays qui mettent de qui produisent le
pétrole ce sont bien des compagnies et
ces compagnies en a de plusieurs types
les premières c'est les ce qu'on appelle
les national oil companies les
compagnies nationales dans les pays
producteurs c'est des très gros
producteurs les compagnies
internationales privées du genre total
energy c'est une autre catégorie et puis
vous avez une myiade vraiment des des
milliers de petites moyennes compagnies
qui participent aussi à à
l'approvisionnement donc ces flèches ce
sont ces grandes compagnies pour vous
donner un ordre de grandeur Sodi Ramco
ils sont en monopole sur la production
en Arabie Saoudite donc c'est entre 10
et 12 millions de barils par jour euh
ouais je je suis bloqué euh c'est la
suivant s'il vous
plaît
euh donc j'ai dit 100 millions de barils
par jour de de consommation de
production mondiale les grosses
compagnies les plus grosses sodia Ramco
ça produit dizaine de millions de barils
par jour total c'est
1,5 et si on prend les grosses grossse
compagnie du genre total bpchelle et
cetera la la grosse demi-douzaine de de
compagnie c'est à tout cassé 10 % de la
production mondiale hein c'est pas
beaucoup
plus est-ce qu'on va manquer de pétrole
alors là la réponse va être très simple
je peux développer en question si vous
le désirez la réponse est non on a du
pétrole beaucoup plus qu'il n'en faut
des gros des grosses réserves à noter
sur cette carte quelque chose
d'intéressant j'ai dit tout à l'heure le
premier producteur c'est les États-Unis
c'est pas eux qui ont forcément la plus
grosse les plus grosses
réserves c'est une beauté du marché du
pétrole c'est un nonsens économique la
production de de de pétrole au sens où
on produit prioritairement là où il y a
peu de réserves et où c'est très cher
aux États-Unis par exemple et on limite
la production là où il y en a beaucoup
et que ça coûte pas cher par exemple en
Arabie Saoudite et donc ça ça rappelle
que le marché du pétrole c'est un marché
au sens économique du terme il y a aussi
beaucoup de politiqu derrière
et en réalité les les réserves je peux
expliquer pourquoi je vais pas le faire
dans ma présentation mais elles ne
cessent d'augmenter on n'arrête pas
d'augmenter la production et les
réserves augmentent que ce soit pour le
pétrole ou sur le gaz donc nous on va
pas manquer de pétrole le vrai problème
du pétrole c'est le climat il faut qu'on
sorte de la consommation de pétrole pas
parce qu'il y a un risque d'en manquer
mais parce que il y a une urgence
climatique alors il y a des scénarios
qui sont faits pour savoir que est-ce
que c'est possible
euh l'organisme qui fait probablement
référence en la matière c'est l'agence
internationale de de l'énergie alors il
fait pas des des prévisions il fait des
scénarios et ces scénarios c'est c'est
excusez-moi C scénarios
c'est le premier steps c'est en tenant
compte des politiques publiques qui sont
actuellement en œuvre qu'est-ce que ça
va donner à l'horizon 2050 et on voit
que ça baisse surtout pour le P pour le
charbon un peu moins pour le pétrole et
le gaz naturelut plutôt dire que ça
stagne à politique constante si on
regarde le deuxèe scénario c'est les
promesses qui ont été faites par les
pays en matière de transition
énergétique notamment dans le cadre des
accords de Paris là c'est déjà plus
ambitieux on voit que ça baisse partout
le charbon le pétrole le gaz le dernier
scénario net zer emissions c'est ce
qu'il faudrait faire le parcours qu'il
faudrait avoir pour
s'en pour respecter les accords de Paris
et donc limiter le réchauffement
climatique à 1,5 degr d'ici la fin du
siècle on est très loin par rapport aux
politiques qui sont actuellement suivies
et même par rapport aux promesses qui
sont faites de ce qu'il faudrait faire
mais quoi qu'il en soit ça baisse et
c'est globalement remplacé par des
renouvelables et du
nucléaire je vous passe ça euh il y a
d'autres organismes qui font des
prévisions ça c'est Bloomberg par
exemple qui fait aussi des scénarios ça
a globalement la même la même tête hein
ils font des hypothèses un petit peu
différentes sur le captage la
possibilité de capter le CO2
l'utilisation de l'hydrogène et cetera
mais la philosophie est la même le
pétrole l'usage du pétrole du gaz du
charbon va baisser et ça va être
remplacé par en fait une électrification
et dans certains cas autre chose à noter
que dans le plus mauvais scénario par
rapport à la transition climatique
de de Laia de de la pardon c'est donc
c'est ce scénario là où ça stagne mais à
noter que si on regarde comment les
choses évoluent ça c'est les différentes
prévisions qui ont été faites au cours
de ces 5 dernières années par rapport à
l'évolution du gaz cette année-ci il
considère que ça va stagner il y a
encore 5 ans il pensait étant donné les
politiques qui étaient applicables à
l'époque que ça allait augmenter et et
pas un peu hein donc c'est quelque chose
qui évolue très vite le le net zéro il
évolue pas ça on sait qu'on doit baisser
quasiment à zéro les politiques
publiques qui sont mises en œuvre elles
évoluent assez
rapidement
euh je vais la rapidement mais une chose
importante le gaz le pétrole le charbon
ça' baisse c'est remplacé pas tellement
pas tant par des économies d'énergie
alors si une meilleure efficacité
énergétique mais globalement la
considère que dans les 30 prochaines
années 25 prochaines années on va
globalement consommer la même chose
c'est juste que le mix énergétique sera
différent et on va surtout avoir cours à
de l'éolien du Solair euh un peu de
nucléaire euh et des d'autres énergies
alors ça peut être euh de la biomasse
par exemple
euh enfin des bioénergies euh qui pose
problème aussi le le vrai défi c'est
l'électrification hein que ça soit
l'électrification dans l'industrie pour
pour arrêter de consommer du charbon
dans les buildings pour arrêter de
consommer du gaz qu'on utilise surtout
pour pour du chauffage euh et le pétrole
donc dans le transport et c'est possible
c'est possible pas de tout électrifier
et et la partie blanche qu'on ne peut
pas électrifier les solutions c'est
essentiellement l'hydrogène et euh les
biocarburants un mot sur bah
l'électrification de l'automobile on est
en train de vivre une vraie rupture euh
technologique sociétale ça c'est les
ventes de voitures neuves en France le
mois dernier 30 % des voitures vendues
en décembre dernier en France c'était
des électriques alors au sens de
purement électrique
ou hybride
rechargeable ça va très vite le modèle
en l'occurrence c'est la Norvège la
Norvège il y a quasiment plus de diesel
et d'essences qui sont vendues euh on
est à quasi plus de 90 % euh
électrique ou
électrifiable et ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir que ça va très vite en
moins de 7 8 ans ils sont passés de
quelques pourcent à un parcut alors
c'est pas le parc automobile c'est les
ventes automobiles hein après ça il y a
la flotte automobile qu'il faut
remplacer petit à petit euh mais quoi
qu'il arrive on considère que la
tendance générale et pas seulement dans
les pays riches dans les pays euh dans
dans l'ensemble du monde ça va vers une
électrification plus ou moins rapide
selon les scénarios la Chine est
largement en avance maintenant sur
l'Europe les États-Unis plutôt en retard
mais c'est quelque chose qui va se faire
alors avec la nécessité aussi de gérer
tous les rebus qu'on qu'on envoie
aujourd'hui en Afrique ou dans les pays
en développement et qui vont continuer à
polluer mais à nouveau c'est pas
l'Afrique he aujourd'hui qui qui
consomme du pétrole euh donc c'est pas
les grandes masses c'est pas sur sur ça
qu'il faut agir
euh on voit que quel que soit le
scénario en gros on décarbonise et on
électrifie surtout le transport routier
ici c'est beaucoup plus compliqué pour
le maritime et l'aviation je peux en
dire un mot mais c'est pas avant 2040
qu'on va commencer à voir des des
changements et ça repose quand même sur
des technologies qui pour le moment sont
au niveau de l'expérience hein
l'hydrogène par exemple pour les avions
et les bateaux et même les les biofuels
on en a encore très très loin de de la
phase
industrielle ah oui peut-être juste un
mot à noter que plus on va vite dans la
réduction de la demande plus on
considère que la baisse du prix du
pétrole va se faire rapidement euh dans
une perspective de justice sociale où ce
sont les plus pauvres qui vont
probablement mettre le plus de temps à
électrifier leur véhicules c'est quelque
chose de d'assez important à avoir en
tête je vous ai mis des chiffres que je
vais pas commenter si vous êtes plus
intéressé en détail par les les
prédictions enfin les les scénarios de
de laiee alors qu'est-ce que peut faire
le législateur dans ce contexte euh on
peut jouer sur l'offre
euh c'est-à-dire voir où vont les
investissements alors les
investissements aujourd'hui ils se font
en fait majoritairement euh dans les
Renou là pour la production
d'électricité alors le l'amont pétrolier
et gazier ça occupe quand même toujours
une part importante mais la tendance
c'est qu'on investit de plus en plus
dans le renouvelable et dans les
solutions électriques et de moins en
moins dans les énergies fossile
euh les montants qui sont investis sont
quand même assez importants on est
depuis 10 ans alors il y a le le trou du
covid mais sinon on est globalement à
100 milliards de d'euros de dollars
d'investissement par an dans le charbon
le gaz naturel le pétrole et ça ça ça
prend en compte la production le
transport le raffinage enfin toutes les
infrastructures nécessaires et cetera
100 milliards quand même par an 1000
pardon 1000 milliards d'euros par an
dans dans dans dans le secteur alors à
contrario donc ça ça stagne pour les
pour les le pérole et le gaz ça augmente
très clairement pour les énergies
propres laie considère clean énergie que
que le le le nucléaire est une clean
énergie tout le monde est pas forcément
d'accord sur la nomenclature mais pour
information dans leur statistique à eux
il le il le considèrent comme ça total
et les grandes compagnies pétrolières
elles produisent quand même encore ils
investissent surtout dans dans du
pétrole et du gaz sur 20 milliards
d'investis donc total ils investissent
20 sur un total de 1000 hein et dans ces
20 il y en a 16 pour le pétrole et le
gaz qu pour d'autres solutions bas
carbone dans le casadre total c'est
essentiellement de l'énergie solaire aux
États-Unis et en Inde
euh est-ce que Total est pire ou
meilleur que que les autres bon une
manière de regarder c'est ça
total comme toutes les autres grandes
compagnies internationales ils ont un
code de conduite très strict ils ont une
politique de
RSE très développé
exactement en pratique ça ne les empêche
d'investir nulle part il n'y a aucun
pays quasiment où vraiment ils se disent
c'est pas possible la corruption en
Angola c'est pas un obstacle la guerre
civile en Libye c'est pas un obstacle la
la nature du régime en en en Birmanie
c'est pas forcément un obstacle non
plus les seules exceptions c'est
lorsqu'il y a des
sanctions total est parti de Russie un
peu à reculon mais parce que c'est une
obligation légale et puis lorsqu'ils
sont directement attaqués au Yémen ils
sont partis parce que c'était juste plus
possible de continuer à
travailler en en Mozambique c'est
compliqué également donc c'est ça qui
les fait partir c'est pas les droits de
l' h c'est pas la stabilité politique du
régime c'est pas les les éventuels
problèmes environnementaux et cetera et
cetera les compagnies ont quand même des
choix qu'il peuvent faire pour faire
plus ou moins bien leur métier ils
peuvent choisir quel type de produit il
ils décident d'investir le pétrole et le
gaz c'est pas tout la même chose il y a
des des pétroles qui sont nettement plus
problématique d'un point de vue
environnemental le gaz c'est déjà mieux
et total fait à peu près moitié moitié
gaz et pétrole et est plutôt pas
n'investit plutôt plus dans les pétroles
les plus problématiques je pense par
exemple au sable bitumineux en en au
Canada les techniques de production peuv
ai varier par exemple la fracture la
fracturation hydraulique est plus
problématique que des des des des
techniques de production normale et puis
il y a bah tout ce qui sont les
meilleures pratiques de de l'ensemble
des acteurs sur le torchage le fait
qu'on brûle du gaz à la sortie d'un
puits de pétrole c'est de la pure perte
économique
environnementale
énergétique les fuites de
méthane c'est quelque chose de très très
problématique aussi dans l'industrie il
y a des entreprises qui sont plus
regardantes ou que d'autres mais à
nouveau total c'est 1,5 % de la
production
mondiale si on prend les grandes
entreprises européennes sur lequel les
législateurs français européens peuvent
espérer légiférer c'est entre 5 et 10 %
alors selon qu'prend les Anglais et les
Norvégiens avec nous c'est pas là-dessus
qu'on qu'il y a un vrai levier pour
changer et pour accélérer la la la
sortie du pétrole et du gaz il faut
jouer sur la demande et la demande c'est
d'ailleurs ce que Total dit total dit
moi je réponds à la
demande si je produis du pétrole c'est
parce que il y a des gens qui veulent me
l'acheter et ils ont pas tort
euh effectivement euh c'est sur la
demande c'est la demande qu'il faut
réduire à la fois la quantité d'énergie
qu'on utilise et puis le le type
d'énergie qu'on qu'on utilise et là le
législateur a la possibilité de fixer
des normes d'utiliser l'instrument
fiscal donner des subdit pour les bonnes
pratiques euh ou ou ou la bonne
technologie ou au contraire taxer les
mauvaises pratiques et les les mauvaises
technologies alors sachant que les taxes
on le voit encore aujourd'hui c'est
socialement très problématique il y a un
vrai une vraie question de justice
sociale à à prendre en compte mais en
même temps et on l'a vu en 2022
2023 le prix c'est le meilleur
instrument pour orienter la consommation
hein quand le prix du gaz a augmenté à
cause de la guerre en Ukraine les gens
ont arrêté de consommer du gaz on ça a
baissé de 20 % parce que le prix s'est
envolé et c'est quand même là-dessus
qu'on peut jouer l'État peut aussi
investir dans des infrastructures pour
orienter la consommation le type de
consommation et puis peut faire un
effort sur soi-même
euh l'État pourrait décider que en 2025
euh tous les nouveaux achats de de
véhicules devraient être basse basse
émission c'est pas difficile à faire
euh alors voilà il y a un problème
économique euh mais c'est un problème
qu'on demande à tout le monde maintenant
rien n'empêche de en parallèle taxer
certaines choses
euh les le carburant pour aviation n'est
pas taxé on se demande bien pourquoi euh
il y a pas de TVA sur les sur les ticket
d'avion on se demande bien aussi
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui où est la
logique sa chant que ça profite plutôt
aux classes aisé et que l'avion c'est
vraiment le pire truc en matière de de
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre les
entreprises il faut aussi les cibler
elles les transporteurs routiers les
taxis il faut les aider dans cette
transition et à nouveau on peut les
aider avec la carotte ou avec le bâton
c'est selon et bah plus c'est
intelligent plus on a de chance que ça
fonctionne et puis surtout les ménages
c'est c'est eux les les consommateurs
finaux et c'est vraiment il y a un enjeu
énorme pour que le législateur prennent
les bonnes mesures pour accélérer cette
transition ce changement de mode de vie
pour privilégier les transports en
commun par rapport à la voiture
privilégier une voiture électrique par
rapport à une voiture à essence
privilégier les petits véhicules par
rapport au gros SUV tout ça c'est
quelque chose que le législateur peut
euh peut pousser dans un sens ou dans
l'autre je m'arrête là je vous remercie
je suis à votre entière disposition pour
des questions parf ce que je vous
propose c'est d'abord euh que le
rapporteur vous pose une batterie de
question et ensuite je me tournerai vers
chacun de nos collègues étant entendu
que question courte répondes précise ce
sera l'idéal si on veut pouvoir avancer
merci merci monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
merci infiniment pour votre présentation
qui commence à nous donner un cadre sur
sur le
pétrole vous avez mentionné plusieurs
choses et y compris du fait de votre
expertise j'aimerais vous interroger
premièrement sur au fond cette
géopolitique du pétrole dans un monde où
l'accaparement des ressources est un
enjeu stratégique
absolu qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire aussi des risque de stabilité des
risques de tension que ce soit à
l'échelle internationale comme à
l'échelle des pays cette économie du
pétrole génère ou implique vous avez
mentionné et vous avez dans vos
écrits pas
mal développé sur ce qu'on a pu appeler
en économie la malédiction du pétrole
c'estd qu'au fond cette ressource qui
peut apparaître comme un un enjeu ou un
potentiel d'enrichissement pour beaucoup
de société ça a créé beaucoup de malheur
et pas beaucoup de démocratie et donc il
y a ce premier bloc qui est il y a une
géopolitique du pétrole qui est aussi
une géopolitique du risque à tout point
de vue encore une fois dans les états
comme au niveau international le deuxème
point sur lequel vous êtes moins
intervenu également c'est la rentabilité
considérable de l'économie du pétrole
vous avez
mentionné 75 dollars le baril au fond à
ce rythme
là cette économie est extrêmement
rentable et n'a de fait quasiment aucun
intérêt à changer à
évoluer dans un monde où l'Agence
internationaleénergie recommande de
stopper tout nouveau ve
projets pétrole gaz charbon comment au
fond on
articule cette extrême rentabilité de
l'économie du pétrole et évidemment le
la nécessité d'en sortir dernier
point vous avez parlé de totale énergie
aujourd'hui effectivement il y a eu un
certain nombre de rapports on le verra
au cours des auditions qui disent que
Total énergie est un des groupes qui
investit le plus euh sur euh le pétrole
le gaz y compris dans des zones
euh difficiles euh quel est au fond euh
au-delà de ce que vous avez dit sur les
leviers de demande euh vous avez repris
l'argument total qui de dire au fond moi
je fais que répondre à la demande en
réalité c'est quand même un jeu entre
l'offre et la demande je veux dire plus
on ira chercher du pétrole et plus on le
rendra pas cher disponible abondant et
moins il sera facile d'en sortir donc
sur ces trois aspects j'aimerais vous
entendre d'accord je vous remercie alors
sur sur le premier point de de
géopolitique de du pétrole euh alors oui
il y a une géopolitique du pétrole parce
que euh le pétrole c'est un bien qui est
nécessaire à tout le monde euh et en
particulier aux grandes puissances
puisque c'est une condition pour avoir
pour pouvoir faire la guerre euh pour
pouvoir être intégré au commerce et donc
il revient à tous les gouvernements de
s'assurer du bon approvisionnement de de
de l'économie en pétrole ce que
l'histoire nous montre et on peut je
pourrais remettre les cartes mais c'est
pas forcément utile il y a des pays qui
s'en sortent très bien sans avoir une
goutte de pétrole hein le Japon Taïwan
la Corée la France l'Allemagne bah tout
ça tous ces pays se sont assez bien
industrialisés sont devenus riches sont
devenus puissants sans pétrole ce qui
compte ce n'est pas de contrôler de la
production c'est d'assurer la sécurité
des flux d'approvisionnement et là il
faut vraiment se mettre dans une
logique d'un marché global
libéralisé il y a un fantasme par
rapport au au pétrole euh ça c'est
c'était vrai probablement il y a 50 ans
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucun pays qui
s'approvisionne en étant en relation
privilégiée avec un pays producteur hein
ça c'était le le schéma gaulien de la
France en Afrique ça n'existe plus
aujourd'hui on a on est sur un marché
libéralisé s'il y a du pétrole qui
arrive en France c'est parce
que bah on paye le le prix et ce prix là
il est le même pour tout le monde les
Chinois les Français les Américains ou
les Luxembourgeois euh il y a quand même
une puissance qui est un petit peu
particulière dans ce schéma qui est les
États-Unis les États-Unis ne cherche pas
à contrôler la production la production
elle viendra de toute façon sur le
marché hein ce qui ce que font les les
Américains c'est d'essayer de enfin ils
font deux choses la première c'est
d'essayer de libéraliser le marché au
plus possible c'est-à-dire de permettre
aux compagnies pétrolières
internationales américaines ou autres he
c'est du c'est une pure logique
libérale au sens de l'idéologie libérale
que si on laisse les compagnies faire
leurs petites affaires on aura un
optimum en terme d'allocation des
ressources c'est-à-dire on va produire
le pétrole qu'il faut pour répondre à la
demande et ça marche assez bien il n'y a
plus que deux pays dans le monde qui
n'ont pas
libéralisé leur domain pétrolier alors
il y a il y a des des degrés qui sont
différents mais il y a que deux pays où
les compagnies pétrolières étrangères ne
peuvent pas aller c'est l'Arabie
Saoudite et le kwiit dans tous les
autres y compris au Venezuela où il y a
des grands discours nation nationaliste
y compris dans la Russie de Poutine où
il y avait aussi des grands discours
nationalistes les entreprises étrangères
sont plus ou moins le bienvenu en Iran
aussi parce que ces pays ont besoin des
capitaux étrangers de l'accès à la
technologie la deuxième chose que font
les Américains c'est de sécuriser ce
marché c'estàd d'être sûr que les flux
voyagent bien depuis les pays
producteurs vers les pays consommateurs
et l'essentiel de ces flux se font par
voie maritime
les américains c'est la seule grande
puissance qui a une présence navale sur
l'ensemble des océans et qui peut alors
à la fois sécuriser les flux ils le font
aujourd'hui enfin ils essayent de le
faire en en mer Rouge ils peuvent aussi
les interrompre ils pourrait très bien
couper l'approvisionnement d'un pays euh
tout le monde s'en accommode sauf les
Chinois évidemment les chinois ils ont
bien vu que ça ça leur posait un
problème et donc ils développent une une
stratégie différente mais là la vraie
géopolitique elle est pas celle-là et on
fait pas la guerre aujourd'hui pour
s'accaparer du pétrole ça c'est un
fantasme pourra parler de la guerre en
Irak en 202 en 2003 le but c'est pas
d'aller contrôler les réserves
pétrolières irakiennes elles sont de
toute façon
produites quoi qu'il arrive le but enfin
o là où il y a un risque de guerre
pardon c'est effectivement lié à la
malédiction du pétrole c'est-à-dire
qu'on voit de manière très
contre-intuitive que assez souvent enfin
qu'il y a une corrélation si vous voulez
entre le fait d'être très dépendant de
la production de ressources naturel et
en particulier
énergétique pétrole gaz on pourrait dire
uranium pour le Niger et puis donc une
corrélation négative entre cette
dépendance à la production de ressources
et le et le développement du pays en
gros plus vous
êtes dépendant de de ces matières Pr
prère de de votre économie dépend de ces
matières premières moins vous êtes
développé alors il y a des contreexemple
et et c'est évidemment là-dessus qu'on
qu'on fantasme le Qatar oui il vit très
bien grâce à ça mais à côté de ça
regardez le Venezuela regardez l'Algérie
par rapport au Maroc regardez le
nigerriia regardez l'Angola regardez
même un pays comme le Mozambique avant
même de commencer à produire ils sont
déjà en train de d'avoir les contrecp de
ce qu'on appelle cette malédiction du
pétrole et donc là oui il y a des
guerres qui peuvent être générées du
fait de cette production de de pétrole
ou en tout cas une instabilité très
importante ça c'est tout à fait certain
euh ma deuxème la deuxième question
était sur la
rentabilité
h alors oui c'est extrêmement rentable
alors pas pas toujours
hein en Arabie Saoudite ça coûte 5 10
dollars de produire un baril et puis il
le vendent 75 aux
États-Unis où il développe beaucoup de
la production de pétrole de schiste donc
du pétrole non conventionnel on est
plutôt à 50 voire plus dollars donc la
la marche serait Trécis quand
même depuis les années 70 la grande
bataille ça a été l'accaparement de
cette de cette 30 pétrolière et dans les
années 80 enfin 70 et 80 ce sont
vraiment les étapes producteurs qui ont
mis la main surtout dans à l'OPEP sur
ce sur sur l'essentiel de des
bénéfices alors à nouveau en augmentant
leur dépendance l'Arabie Saoudite on ils
sont très riches mais ils ont besoin que
le pétrole soit à 75 dollars pour avoir
un budget public équilibré sinon il ne
s'en sortent pas et c'est un cas
classique de malédiction du pétrole
l'Arabie Saoudite vit essenti iement du
pétrole et a une population de gens qui
ne travaillent pas réellement enfin en
tout cas pas les pas les locaux alors
quand vous êtes le Qatar et le KT que
vous êtes tout petit vous pouvez vous
permettre quand vous êtes l'Iran ça
marche déjà plus vous êtes quasiment 80
100 millions d'habitants vous pouvez pas
avoir tous ces gens oisifs au Nigéria
c'est une catastrophe ils sont 200
millions 200 millions d'habitants et ils
espèrent tous pouvoir vivre du pétrole
c'est pas possible et même l'Arabie
Saoudite aujourd'hui sont 30 millions le
le leur système ne va pas durer comme ça
vitam etnam ils vont avoir un vrai
problème d'ordre
financier total où les grandes
compagnies là-dedans alors elles font
beaucoup de bénéfices et c'est des
bénfices qui sont très impressionnants
en valeur absolu si on les rapporte à
leur chiffre
d'affaires c'est confortable y a pas de
souci mais ça n'a rien à voir avec les
profits que font les Amazon les Apple et
cetera en terme de rentabilité du Cap
capital euh les grosses compagnies
pétrolières ils sont ça c'est ça marche
bien mais c'est c'est pas là que que se
trouve le scandale je dirais
euh voilà
euh la dernière question c'était sur
justement comment on sort de ces de ces
revenus et comment on incite les groupes
à se réorienter d'autres énergies ouais
donc tout toutes les grandes compagnies
c'est des compagnies privées euh leur
but il ne s'en cachent pas c'est de
faire du bénéfice et de distribuer des
dividendes aux actionnaires ils le
disent clairement et enfin on peut
trouver ça bien ou choquant peu importe
c'est pas le débat c'est c'est ça qui
les motive bah la question c'est il faut
faire en sorte que un dollar investi
dans du pétrole rapporte moins que un
dollar investi dans des autres solutions
euh et ça c'est à travers la fiscalité à
travers des normes que ça peut se faire
euh toutes ces grandes compagnies elles
ont toute la prétention de devenir des
compagnies non plus pétrolières mais des
compagnies énergétiques et elles
connaissent très bien les graphiques de
de la elles savent très bien donc toutes
ces compagnies elles elles sont
centenaires elles savent parfaitement
que si elles veulent toujours exister
dans 100 ans elles ne seront plus
compagniees pétrolièr ça il y a pas de
doute donc elles doivent aller là où euh
va le marché et le marché aujourd'hui
c'est de plus en plus effectivement des
renouvelables c'est pas sûr que ce soit
ces compagniesl qui euh vont euh vont
vont vont toutes survivre mais c'est
celles qui euh qui s'y adapte à à cette
évolution qui qui pourront qui pourront
survivre et à ce point de vue-là les
européennes sont plutôt mieux que les
Américaines je dirais hein maintenant à
nouveau c'est la logique d'une compagnie
c'est la rentabilité et donc il faut
faire en sorte
que soit la demande baisse soit la
rentabilité soit moindre et total
s'adaptera comme des
autres merci alors on va essayer d'aller
un peu plus vite parce que je vous
rappelle que nous avons une deuxème
audition
à je prends alors j'ai vu monsieur tisso
monsieur Weber qui d'autre allez-y
allez-y oui merci merci monsieur le
Président euh d'abord merci pour vos
propos limininaires avec mes excuses
pour m'être absenter quelques instants
c'est le télcopage des des emplois du
temps je devis intervenir en séance
publique très rapidement euh moi j'ai
quelques questions rapides et très
directes
euh concernant total bien sûr le projet
tilanga en en Ouganda du groupe Total
prévoit le forrage de 400 puits de
pétrole en bordure du lac Albert et on
sait que ça contraint l'expropriation de
famille ougandaise et au dépôt du
recours devant le tribunal judiciaire de
Paris en juin 2023 et pouvez-vous nous
préciser les relations entretenues entre
par le groupe Total avec le gouvernement
ougandais est-ce que l'intérêt
économique pour le pays est le seul
facteur misise en avant et comment se
positionne l'ambassade de France en
ouanda à ce sujet et ma deuxème question
l'Angola a récemment annoncé se retirer
de l'OPEP on sait que le groupe Total
gère plus de 41 % du marché du pétrole
angolais quelle conséquence pourrait
avoir ce retrait qui pourrait laisser
penser à une réorientation économique et
énergétique de la part de l'Angola ça
rejoint un petit peu ce que vous nous
disiez pour le groupe Total et à ce trou
à ce titre pardon pourriez-vous nous
préciser les relations de total avec
l'OPEP et une troisème question non non
non non non non une question ou deux
questions mais trois là jeis bloquer les
autres c'est la première audition donc
faut qu'on se oui mais il va falloir se
mettre au rythme allez deux questions
c'est déjà bien monsieur alors sur
l'oganda je connais pas les détails du
projet et donc je suis pas capable de le
juger de manière évidente un groupe
comme Total et à nouveau c'est dans la
logique de grandes entreprises il est
pas là pour faire le développement de
l'Ouganda il est là pour faire du
business et il le fait dans le cadre des
contraintes réglementaires qui lui sont
donné le problème c'est qu'en Ouganda
les normes environnementales les normes
de sécurité les normes sociales sont
soit FAI soit
inexistante et donc sur cette question
alors de de l'Ouganda ou des pays en
développement en général l'important
c'est de légiférer dans un cadre
transnational c'est-à-dire faire en
sorte que
les acteurs qui sont sur le marché
européen parce qu'ils sont originaires
ou parce qu'ils sont actifs sur le
marché européen ou sur l'OCDE ça peut
être n'importe quel cadre soit contraint
de respecter les mêmes normes ici que
là-bas enfin ou là-bas que ici et et et
et total le fera total se met en règle
avec les règles ils sont pas ils sont
pas plus vertueux que ça ils vont pas
faire de l'excès de Zè donc s'il y a pas
si il leurait permis juridiquement
d'aller creuser dans la forêt ils iront
creuser dans la forêt euh et alors après
ça est-ce que ça va déboucher sur du
développement en en Ouganda ben non
l'expérience des pays africains des pays
en développement montre que les chances
que ça se passe sont quasi nuls et alors
étant donné la nature du régime en
Ouganda encore plus il faut pas se
leurer mais c'est l'argument classique
de bah ils vont recevoir des milliards à
eux d'en faire bon usage on sait bien
qu'ils vont pas en faire bon usage mais
voilà il y a rien qui interdit à Total
d'aller le faire et sur les relations de
total avec l'Ouganda j'ai pas
d'information particulière pense que
c'est les relations normales qu'une
grande entreprise entretient avec un
état haute il doit signer des contrats
pour avoir des licences euh voilà ça
c'est c'est normal l'ambassade de
franche aucune idée euh sur l'Angola
qu'est-ce que change le retrait de
l'OPEP rien euh à la limite
ça va même
plutôt donc l'Angola est pas content des
des quotas qui lui sont
attribués parce que bah il voudrait
pouvoir produire un peu plus
effectivement les entreprises privées
qui sont là elles sont pas très
contentes hein quand un pays décide de
restreindre sa production ils ont
investi des milliards qui sont rentables
s'ils peuvent produire si après on leur
dit merci d'avoir investi mais en fait
vous pouvez pas produire ils sont pas
contents donc j' imagine que Total est
plutôt content que de le voir sortir de
l'OPEP mais en réalité ça va pas
vraiment changer quoi grand-chose ils
produisent autant qu'ils peuvent point
très bien monsieur Weber oui merci
monsieur le Président je ferai référence
si vous voulez bien à un article paru en
2007 intitulé pétrole facteur de de
violence politique où vous écriviez que
la rente pétrolière dans les pays
producteurs participe à des mécanismes
de dstructuration économique et vous
vous expliquz dans cet article que la
rente sirrée de l'exploitation des
gisements d'hydrocarbures tend à rendre
toute activité économique agricole ou
industrielle non compétitive voire à la
faire disparaître vous supposez alors
une corrélation négative entre la
croissance économique et l'exploitation
du gaz et du Pétrole vous alliez par
ailleurs vous considériez que le pétrole
comme facteur d'instabilité politique en
réalité je souhaiterais savoir si cette
cet article de 2007 et le constat que
vous faisiez à l'époque si vous le
partagez encore aujourd'hui si vous le
semblez encore pertinent aujourd'hui et
pensez-vous qu'une compagnie pétrolière
peut au-delà des seuls enjeux
économiques détenir une véritable
responsabilité politique et une
influence sur le développement
administratif et Industri et
institutionnel d'un État souverain euh
alors je changerai pas une ligne de ce
que vous avez dit un mot même à une
virgule je peux vous expliquer pourquoi
c'est-à-dire que dans un pays qui
commence à produire du pétrole du gaz du
diamant de l'uranium et cetera c'est un
marché qui est mondial il va le vendre
sur sur un marché il va recevoir en
échange des dollars parce que tout ça se
négocie en dollar et cette entrée de
dollars dans l'économie nationale a un
effet sur le taux de change réel de sa
propre monnaie qui s'évalue si la
monnaie locale d'un pays s'évalue ça
signifie qu'il devient de moins en moins
compétitif donc en pratique ça veut dire
que la production locale devient moins
compétitive que la production a importé
et donc petit à petit ce qu'on voit
c'est que dans tous ces pays ça devient
simplement plus rationnel d'importer ce
dont on a besoin plutôt que d'essayer de
le fabriquer soi-même et prenez à
nouveau tous les pays que j'ai cité tout
à l'heure il ne l'Arabie Saoudite ils ne
produisent rien d'autre que du pétrole
et du gaz il serait pas rentable
l'Algérie c'est c'est même chose ils ont
essayé de se diversifier c'est très
compliqué ça ne marche pas alors la
Norvège le Botswana sont des bons
exemples de pays qui ont réussi à à à
sortir de cette malédiction
ça nécessite en fait d'avoir une grosse
enfin une gouvernance solide le problème
du pétrole du gaz de ces ressources là
c'est qu'on a plutôt tendance à
déstructurer le système politique
également dans un système normal je sais
pas si la France est un pays normal
disons que la France est un pays normal
le gouvernement se finance en taxant
l'activité économique ça ne peut être
possible que si les gens acceptent de
payer des impôts il faut qu' ils
acceptent et il faut qu'il y ait une
base pour pouvoir le taxer donc qui a de
l'activité économique dans un système
pétrolier il y a ni l'un ni l'autre le
gouvernement reçoit des milliards de la
part des compagnies qui opèent les
champs qui payent des dividends qui paye
des pardon des royalties qui payent des
impôts il n'a le gouvernement de
l'Angola n'a pas à se soucier de savoir
si la population veut bien payer des des
taxes il n'a pas besoin de ça et même si
la population ne produit rien comme
valeur ajoutée le gouvernement peut
manger du Homar et boire du champagne
sans aucun problème et donc on a plutôt
tendance à avoir une dstructuration des
systèmes de gouvernance alors que c'est
justement ça qu'il faut pour pouvoir
gérer le problème de la malédiction des
ressources et juste un dernier mot
là-dessus le le la puce à l'oreille a
été mise dès les années 70 dans ce qu'on
a appelé à l'époque la Dutch disease la
maladie hollandaise et je je j'insiste
là-dessus pour souligner que c'est pas
une affaire de pays du tiersmonde de
pays sous-développés c'est un mécanisme
de dstructuration de l'économie qu'on a
vu à l'œuvre au Pays-Bas alors au
Pays-Bas ils avaient les ressources
politiques institutionnelles pour pour
pour rectifier le cas euh et aujourd'hui
la Norvège oui ils produisent du pétrole
mais ils payent l'essence encore plus
cher que nous alors maintenant ils en
ont de moins en moins besoin tout le
monde travaille en Norvège normalement
c'est un pays normal ils sont pas là
tous à attendre en se disant le le le
pétrole va va faire et le gaz vont vont
permettre des revenus ils ont des
revenus
supplémentaires mais ils se gardent bien
de l'injecter tel quel dans l'économie
ils ont ce qu'ils appellent un fond pour
les générations futures c'est une
manière de tésoriser les revenus et
justement d'éviter cette distorsion
monétaire qui est à la base de la
malédiction des pétroles qu'est-ce que
peut faire une compagnie pétrolière
alors c'est toute la limite de la de la
TR de la responsabilité sociale des
entreprises oui bah elles disent tous
qu'elles œuvrent en faveur des droits de
l'homme du meilleur respect de
l'environnement et
cetera après ça c'est elle reste dans le
cadre de la loi et puis certaines
essayent d'aller un petit peu plus loin
d'autres un peu moins loin ça fait pas
Infiné des très très grosses différences
elle pourrait alors mais c'est à nouveau
plus dans des obligations légales être
plus transparent sur sur les revenus qui
sont versés au aux États
elles le font maintenant parce que c'est
devenu des obligations légales mais
au-delà de ça c'est effectivement
compliqué et c'est pas leur rôle
probablement à une entreprise d'aller
expliquer un gouvernement comment il
doit il doit se comporter on voudrait
bien qu'il soit un peu plus diligent
face au dictateurs mais on n'aimerait
pas non plus qui soit en train de de
dire à un gouvernement comment eux ils
pensent qu'ils doivent se se comporter
donc est la la limite c'est compliqué on
va essayer pardon d'aller un peu plus
vite parce que évidemment nos invités
sont là depuis un moment les suivants et
je je crains de ne plus avoir grand
monde à la fin de la 2e audition si ça
continue MarieClaire
CARG très rapidement question simple
est-ce qu'il y a des des compagnies qui
sont plus exigeantes que total dans le
monde en terme de RSE et et quel est le
positionnement de de Total vous avez
parlé des techniques d'extraction Torage
et cetera comment ça se situe est-ce
qu'il y a des compagnies exemplaires et
est-ce qu'il y a au niveau international
comme dans le mining un effort pour
élaborer des guidelines de du diligence
comme l'a fait au CDE pour may est-ce
que ça existe est-ce qu'il y a un
parallèle est-ce qu'il faudrait le faire
euh alors c'est très difficile de juger
parce que il y a des aspects sur lequel
total est probablement un bon élève
d'autres oou c'est c'est pas terrible
euh les les acteurs européens sont
plutôt plus soucieux de ces
problématiques notamment
environnementales que les Américains euh
les les les pays en voie de
développement c'est encore pire les euh
et au sein des Européens je dirais que
total c'est plutôt mieux que l'italienne
ENI c'est à peu près la même chose que
Shell et et et BP c'est probablement un
peu moins bien quekinor les les
Norvégiens mais tout ça ça se vaut hein
enfin c'est c'est et puis après ça oui
sur certains points ils peuvent être
mieux et puis sur d'autres ils peuvent
l'être moins parce que un régime
politique évolue en Birmanie au
Mozambique et cetera donc c'est très
difficile euh votre deuxième question
pardon c'est est-ce qu'il y a ah oui
alors est-ce qu'il y a des règles alors
oui dans dans de de de plus en plus
notamment au point de vue de la de la
transparence
financière il y a des des des
obligations au niveau européens il y a
des obligations de due diligence donc
spécifique au secteur pardonnemoioui il
y en a qui sont alors ça c'est pas ça
c'est plus ou moins large sur la
transparence et surtout le secteur
extractif euh parce que les
problématiques des mines sont pas
forcément très éloignées des
problématiques pétrolières gazières euh
sur les questions
euh social alors le social c'est pas
très très problématique hein dans mais
mais oui il y a des des guidelin plus ou
moins c'est il y a tout he il y a tout
il y a des il y a des des trucs qui sont
volontaires d'autres qui sont plus
obligatoires monsieur
Barros merci merci monsieur le Président
merci pour cette cette présentation
malgré les accords de Paris parce qu'ils
ont lieu quand même total énergie
continue toujours d'investir massivement
et vous l'avez bien expliqué dans les
énergies dans les énergies fossiles
l'entreprise a changé de nom total
énergie se présente désormais comme un
groupe
multi-énergie pour répondre justement à
au marché mais cette affirmation manque
masque la réalité d'investissement
réalisé par le groupe en 2025 total
énergie sera la deème major pétrolière
en terme d'expansion et de CO2 émis euh
ceci derrière exon mobile total Energie
a une stratégie de croissance pour
protéger sa capitalisation boursière et
semble comme d'autres entreprises du
secteur investir toujours davantage pour
maintenir et conforter la demande
mondiale tout semble fait pour retarder
au maximum la fin fin de l'exploitation
de gisement il aurait donc aujourd'hui
une forme d'atentisme qui nous conduit
dans le mur j' dirais c'est pas dans le
mur c'est l'explosion du thermomètre les
der5 dans le cadre des cops quelle
solution et vous l'avez un peu exprimé
c'est que c'est on tourne autour un peu
de ce de ce sujet de quelle solutions
les états disposent-il on pourra dire
s'il le souhaitent pour contraindre les
majeurs pétrolièr et modifier leur
stratégie commerciale en effet on
l'offre la demande on sent bien que
l'offre génère aussi de la demande et
vice vera et là il y a certainement un
levier de ce côté-là euh alors je suis
d'accord avec tout ce que vous avez dit
sauf peut-être à la
fin non ils ont pas vraiment d'impact
sur la demande elle-même là où ils ont
un impact éventuellement c'est de se
dire s'ils produisent plus le prix va
baisser donc les consommateurs vont
plus consommer en réalité le pétrole
c'est c'est pas quelque chose qui est où
il a alasticité prix très importante
c'està-dire le le prix à la pompe peut
doubler vous allez pas diminuer de
moitié votre consommation parce que vous
êtes obligé de prendre la voiture mais à
l'inverse même chose c'est pas parce que
demain le prix du pétrole baisse que
vous vousz dire je vais faire trois fois
le tour du péf plutôt que deux euh vous
alors après ça oui il y a la demande qui
est desarbitrages entre est-ce que
j'achète une voiture électrique est-ce
que j'achète une voiture à essence
est-ce que j'achète une GRSE voiture une
petite voiture mais à nouveau c'est pas
directement total ou même les grosses
compagnies qui peuvent avoir un impact
là-dessus alors là où ils ont un un où
ils jouent un jeu c'est de faire croire
que c'est naturel de continuer à à à
avoir du pétrole j'ai montré les les les
scénarios faits par des agences
respectable l'OPEP fait aussi ses
scénarios total fait aussi ses scénarios
et là dans les scénarios de des
pétroliers bah en fait on continue
allègrement à à consommer du pétrole
donc c'est pas qu'ils y croient c'est
que ils envoient un message disant c'est
normal d'aller dans cette direction là
on va diminuer mais pas beaucoup alors
qu'il faudrait de toute façon diminuer
beaucoup mais à nouveau c'est en jouant
sur l'offre et pas sur pardon sur la
demande et pas sur l'offre qu'on y
arrivera total total s'adaptera à
nouveau total ils sont là pour faire du
du pognon
pardon ça commence déjà en fait il
s'adapte oui donc ils investissent alors
ils sont très contents de le de le
publiciser he ils investissent un peu
dans le solaire dans les batteries et
cetera alors ben c'est 4 milliards sur
20 voilà enfin on peut contester les
chiffres c'est pas les miens et j'ai
j'ai sourcé toutes mes tous mes trucs
hein mais voilà ça vous donne un ordre
de grandeur il y a 20 ans c'était proche
du zéro hein donc voilà maintenant
est-ce que ça va assez vite bien sûr que
que non est-ce que si total demain
arrêtait de produire du pétrole est-ce
que réellement on prendrait moins notre
voiture c'est ma question bah
non l'offre serait probablement pourvue
par quelqu'un d'autre si le prix ne
change pas
euh monsieur folio on pour on pourrait
aussi se dire que si toutes les major du
pétrole sortaient des énergies fossiles
il compris du gaz en investissant sur
les énergies renouvelables on aurait une
transition énergétique beaucoup plus
rapide
française alors
ouiende mais et à nouveau ces gens
représentent 10 % de l'offre c'est c'est
alors mais oui bien entendu que si tout
le monde envoie le même message ça fait
avancer le chemil B plus rapidement hein
il y a pas de doute là ce sera difficile
pour notre commission d'enquête monsieur
folio parce que notre influence sur BP
est assez faible monsieur folio merci
monsieur le Président merci tout d'abord
pour votre
présentation juste si j'ai bien saisi
les chiffres que vous vous nous avez
donné euh total est un acteur som tout
presque secondaire tout au moins euh
relativement moins important quand on
compare avec la la compagnie nationale
saoudienne euh et et et et c'est un un
élément important moi je voulais vous
poser une question sur un des éléments
et et un des enjeux euh par rapport à la
loi Hulot euh est-ce que euh vous
considérez pas que notre pays est dans
une posture qui est une posture hypo
crite et égoïste en ce sens qu'on
interdit toute exploration exploitation
d'énergie fossile sur le sol de notre
pays euh tout en euh n'interdisant pas
euh des importations bien sûr parce que
c'est c'est c'est on en a besoin et que
donc dans ce dans ce cadre là quand on
regarde et moi je j'ai j'ai eu
l'occasion d'aller plusieurs fois dans
le cadre d'une mission sénatoriale et et
encore il y a une une quinzaine de jours
sur le PL plateau des Guyana euh vous
parliez de malédiction du pétrole euh
bien sûr sur un pays comme le Guyana le
pétrole peut être considéré comme une
malédiction au travers des menaces du
Venezuela sur la province de
lessquibo mais c'est aussi une
opportunité et par rapport aux échanges
que nous avons eu avec mon collègue
François bonau il y a une quinzaine de
jours avec le président Irfan Ali du
Guyana il y a toute une stratégie euh à
j'is dire entre guillemets pour
caricaturer à la Norvégienne que veut
développer ce pays pour essayer de
sortir de son sous-développement de
protéger sa
forêt équatoriale et et essayer d'avoir
une une dynamique de de de développement
tout à fait euh tout tout tout à fait
intéressante mais voilà moi c'est sur
sur ces éléments d'enjeu je veux dire
par rapport à la aux questions
géostratégiques et j'écoute les les
remarques de nos C collègue guyanais qui
disent som toutes sur ce plateau des
Guyanes il y a des ressources au Guyana
il y en a au Surinam qui ont été
découverte il y en a au Brésil et puis
en guyan française il y en a pas
on veut pas les
voir alors sur votre première question
est-ce que Total est un acteur mineur
non c'est plus important que sa part de
marché ne laisse le suggérer alors en
production ils sont pas très importants
là où ils sont importants c'est que les
compagnies internationales du genre exon
total BP échelle et cetera ont pas du
tout le même profil que les grosses
compagnies nationales dans le sens où
elles ne sont les les les compagnies
internationales sont verticalement
intégrées donc elles sont actives sur
l'ensemble de la chaîne de valeur là où
sodia Ramco ils sont très gros en Arabie
Saoudite et puis c'est tout ils ne sont
pas des acteurs internationaux ils
investissent au fond assez peu dans la
recherche d'exploration production euh
et c'est pas eux qui développent les
technologies donc les les moyens
technologiques qui sont mis en œuvre
c'est le fait des grandes entreprises
privées et plutôt les les les les
grosses alors pas simplement les
compagnies pétrolières c'est aussi les
parapétroliers les schloubergers les les
technipes compagnie française à qui
passent leur temps à essayer d'améliorer
les choses pour pour produire plus euh
mais donc le l'influence d'un d'un
acteur comme total c'est pas uniquement
réductible à sa part de marché de la
production c'est quand même beaucoup
plus large que ça sur euh le le fait
qu'on interdit en France euh mais qu'on
importe alors c'est c'est purement
symbolique euh même si on on essait de
produire autant qu'on peut en France ça
serait une gouttelette par rapport à aux
besoins de la France et rien du tout par
rapport à l'ensemble de la production
mondiale ce qu'on fait ici c'est avec
une loi pareille c'est d'envoyer un
message de dire on on fait un effort de
notre côté euh au fond ça change rien
euh ni sur la consommation est-ce que
vous prenez moins ou plus votre voiture
grâce à la loi hullo bien sûr que non ça
ne change rien euh et euh en terme de
production et de prix sur le marché ça
ne change rien non plus est-ce que ça
donnerait des ressources supplémentaires
au aux régions peut-être à la marge mais
vraiment pas pas grand-chose euh et
quant au Guyana alors ça sort de moi je
connais bien l'Afrique je connais moins
l'Amérique latine et pas du tout le
Guyana
euh je peux vous croire sur le fait
qu'ils disent mettre en place toutes les
mesures de sécurité de sauvegarde pour
s'assurer que l'argent qui va être
généré va servir au développement pour
s'assurer que la production ne causera
pas dans de dégâts environnementaux tous
les pays le font tous ils ont tous le
même discours ce qu'on peut constater
c'est que au au final dans la
réalité dans je dirais 8k sur 10 ça
tourne plutôt au désastre et c'est
plutôt une
malédiction alors peut-être que
miraculeusement le Guyana va va faire
mieux que tous les autres
malheureusement l'expérience en général
c'est pas c'est pas celle-là hein à
nouveau regardez le voisin vénézuélien
ils ont les plus grande réserve de
pétrole du monde
euh dans quel état est l'économie dans
quel état est pays dans quel état est le
régime
voilà merci de nous dire que nous avons
nous sommes battus nous avons voté des
lois qui ne changent rien monsieur
grosallé dans cette dans cette vision
planétaire globalisée mondialisée
ultralibérale que vous vous décrivez si
on rapporte ça l'espace hexagonal et et
donc à la stratégie en France à la fois
d'approvisionnement mais aussi puisque t
est aussi un transformateur et un
distributeur quelle est à la fois la
stratégie de notre pays dans ce dans ce
dans cette vision globalisée pour se
assurer son indépendance et et quelle
est la place de total pour le coup dans
l'espace hexagonal dans cette
stratégie alors je tiens à préciser que
je parle dans ce monde globalisé parce
que j'essaie de vous décrire le monde
tel que je le vois c'est gens jugement
de valeur je vous dis pas que c'est bien
ou que c'est pas bien chacun est peut
juger enfin et moi également j'ai le
droit de juger mais c'est pas ça qui la
question ce que j'essaie de montrer
c'est comment ça marche et donc quand
qu'est-ce qu'il faut prendre en compte
comme réalité pour pouvoir légiférer
pour pouvoir atteindre un but quel que
soit ce
but la France je connais pas
euh la la législation oui il y a des
obligations qui portent pas qui qui
concernent pas une uniquement total qui
concerne les acteurs pétroliers une des
obligations c'est notamment de faire des
du du stock d'avoir des réserves
stratégique donc on a en France comme
dans tout c'est une obligation pas en
France mais dans tous les pays de
l'Agence internationale don en gros de
l' CDE les Chinois font ça aussi c'est
d'avoir 3 mois de réserve donc même si
demain on arrête de
euh de de de recevoir du pétrole
l'étranger on a de quoi tenir entre
guillemets l'équivalent de 3 mois de
consommation puis ça s'arrête hein mais
voilà et donc ça c'est des obligations
qui sont données aux opérateurs
pétroliers qui sont présents sur le
territoire d'avoir des moyens de
stockage et cetera je connais pas les
détails des des de qui paye quoi et et
comment s'organise la loi en la
matière par contre pour la stratégie
d'approvisionnement de la France la
réalité c'est que la France comme tous
les pays à part la Chine profite et
dépend
du système libéralisé et mis en place
par les États-Unis c'est eux qui
sécurisent les routes pétrolières en
pratique et qui font en sorte que ce
pétrole arrive les les les liens entre
total et et l'État français elles sont
aujourd'hui celles d'un état avec une
grande
entreprise c'est pas beaucoup plus
total ne se soucie pas forcément
d'approvisionner la France si demain les
Français ne veulent plus payer leur
pétrole au même prix que les autres
total va arrêter de leur le revendre
hein euh le prix c'est le même pour tout
le monde donc si vous voulez payer total
vous le vendra si vous voulez pas payer
total vous le vendra pas voilà allez une
dernière
[Musique]
intervention merci vous avez évoqué
évidemment et vous venez de l'évoquer
est-ce que la stratégie actuelle de
Total énergie en matière de réduction de
l'empreinte carbone correspond à ce qui
a été décidé par la France notamment
lors des Accords de la COP
alors ça c'est un grand grand débat des
stratégies environnementales des
compagnies pétrolières et de Total en
particulier total dit on va être neutre
en carbone d'ici
2050 neutre en carbone c'est pas qu'on
ne va plus émettre d'émissions mais ça
veut dire que les émissions résiduelles
on va les compenser il y a déjà des
grands plans sur la comèt qui sont fait
sur des technologies qui aujourd'hui
n'existent pas vraiment comme le captage
le stockage de CO2 ça existe pas et ça
pose des vraies questions c'est que le
stockage qu'est-ce qu'on en fait au bout
d'un moment hein ça va voilà on sait pas
euh mais c'est ça qui permet de dire
qu'on va être neutre ce que dit total en
disant je vais être neutre c'est ce
qu'ils appellent leur scope 1 et 2
c'est-à-dire quelles sont les émissions
qui sont générées par mon
activité OK et là il s'engage à éliminer
le torchage à à faire en sorte que en
gros il n'est plus d'émission ils ne
disent pas bien entendu qu'est-ce qui se
passe avec ce qu'ils produisent en
disant c'est le consommateur final qui
va brûler le pétrole et le gaz que j'ai
euh produit et qui est donc responsable
des émissions c'est évidemment un petit
peu hypocrite mais ça c'est
euh le le le scope 3 et c'est bien pour
ça que c'est au législateur à mon sens
devrait et de se focaliser là-dessus
c'est faire en sorte que les
consommateurs finaux qui sont ceux qui
émettent du CO2 en brûlant le pétrole de
Total ou les autres cesse d'utiliser du
pétrole et du gaz hein et donc ça c'est
organiser la transition en particulier
sur le transport et puis pour sur le
gaz la mesure qu'il faut faire c'est
isoler les bâtiments commencer par
celui-ci euh non enfin les non mais
commencer par les les les bâtiments
publics et j'ai ENF voilà et puis aider
aider les gens à isoler leur maison et
alors c'est c'est gagnant sur toute la
ligne vous diminuez vos émissions vous
faites des économies c'est du c'est de
l'emploi local enfin ça ça n'a que des
avantages on le fait pas ou on le fait à
un rythme de
tortue merci allez là je vais devoir
lever cette première audition sinon la
deuxième va être sputnque
merci à vous de cette audition merci de
vos réponses je conseille à nos
collègues d'être plus ramassé pour la
2uxè audition sinon je suis pas sûr de
pas finir tout seul merci infiniment
merci
beaucoup vous donné ça a été envoyé par
mail ça ça a été envoyé par mail merci
infiniment en tout cas de tous ces
éléments merci merci pour votre
invitation merci au
revoirir merci à
vous
avant l'audition madame Sophie prima do
nous faire une courte déclaration
oui je vais essayer de la faire très
courte merci monsieur le président
conformément à une cisine du Comité de
déontologie je voudrais vous faire par
d'un certain nombre d'éléments me
concernant dans sur cette commission
d'enquête j'ai saisi le Comité de
déontologie car je voudrais porter à la
connaissance de la commission que mon
fils exerce une mission de chef de
projet métanisation en région Auvergne
ronalpe dans la société fondroche
énergie biogaz qui est une filiale à 100
% de Total énergie j'ai donc interrogé
le comité deentogie pour savoir si je
devais me déporter complètement de cette
commission d'enquête ou si je pouvais
continuer le comité deontologie m'a
demander d'abord de faire cette
déclaration devant vous à considérer que
je n'exerçais pas de fonction dans la
commission d'enquête de présidente ou de
rapporteur qu'il s'agissait d'une que
mon fils occupe un poste opérationnel
dans une filiale dans une région et non
pas du tout au siège du groupe
d'ailleurs que je serais totalement
étanche par rapport évidemment aux
travaux de la commission comme avec
toute autre personne et que la
production de gaz renouvelable en France
ne fait pas partie des principales
questions soulevées par la résolution
qui tend à créer la commission donc je
voulais vous informer de voilà de cet
état de faite et évidemment si dans le
cadre de nos travaux nous étions amenés
à parler de cette entreprise du Bio gaz
ou d'une entreprise qui pourrait être
concurrente de fond roche énergie je me
déporterai monsieur le Président voilà
merci Madame prima et bien dans le même
ordre d'idée une déclaration du
rapporteur merci monsieur le
Président le Comité de déontologie qui
s'est réuni en amont de cette commission
d'enquête a aussi fait des
recommandations me concernant
euh lors de la campagne présidentielle
j'avais dénoncé le maintien de Total en
Russie après l'invasion de l'Ukraine
euh totale énergie apporté plainte en
diffamation et de fait je suis dans un
contentieux juridique avec total sur les
activités de Total en Russie donc le
Comité de déontologie m'a demandé de me
déporter euh
de ce sujet donc dans le cadre de cette
commission d'enquête quand sera abordée
la question de la Russie et évidemment
la question de la Russie sera abordé je
resterai évidemment déporté de ce point
de vue-là
merci